good morning and welcome
coatsworth Dean of the Columbia School
of International and public affairs I
want to
the third lecture in Sivas leaders in
global energy series the centerpiece of
a new initiative launched by sepa this
fall to identify and learn about
solutions to the challenge of creating
sustainable energy while protecting the
environment and reaffirming corporate
citizenship this initiative has been
made possible through support by energy
is that portable one of Europe's leading
electricity operators I also want to
acknowledge and thank Cephas visiting
professor Manuel Pina former portuguese
minister of economy and innovation
because here in the front row in making
for his initiative and and his energy in
making this series possible professor
Pino as you may know is an
extraordinarily versatile individual he
has just reinvented himself again this
morning launching his new career as a
test driver for Nissan's new electric
car nissan leaf creating sustainable
energy while protecting the environment
and reaffirming corporate citizenship is
one of the great challenges of this
century the leaders in global energy
lecture series is the centerpiece of a
new sepa initiative in this field the
series began this September with a
lecture by Nabu Tanaka managing director
of the International Energy Agency next
we heard from Andre speed box European
Commissioner for development and the
series will conclude on December first
with a talk by fatigue bureau chief
economist at the International Energy
Agency in addition to the leaders in
global energy series sefa is developing
new course work field work and research
through its energy and environment
concentration which provides students
with the knowledge base and analytical
tools needed to address the challenge of
sustainably and responsibly powering the
developed and developing nations of the
world sefa has a unique track record of
empowering people to serve the global
public interest through careers in the
public nonprofit and private sectors and
through research that
points to new forms of collaboration and
development see post ties to the
university's Earth Institute schools of
business and law and departments of
economics and political science create
an ideal interdisciplinary platform for
this initiative we all know that finding
promoting and implementing solutions the
challenge of sustainable energy will
require collaboration by government
corporate and NGO leaders the adoption
of new technologies and the rise of a
new generation of thinkers who can
overcome all the historic barriers to
socially responsible energy policy
making that is why we are especially
pleased and honored to welcome today
carlos tavares and his team as chairman
of nissan america's mr. Tavares
graduated from the Ecole send caught
helada party with the degree in
engineering and is a native of Portugal
he oversees Nissan's operations in North
Central and South America including
manufacturing engineering design sales
and marketing and administration and
finance the whole thing before assuming
his current responsibilities mr. Tavares
supervise dan umber of global functions
for the company including corporate
planning product planning design brand
management sorry design and brand
management market intelligence and the
Infinity and commercial vehicle
businesses it was under his guidance
that Nissan developed its zero emissions
strategy and pursued the development of
electric vehicles in only four years the
results are here on the screen the new
Nissan beach mr. Tavares will speak
about the nissan leaf and zero emission
mobility innovation for the planet
welcome
good morning to everybody mmm and thank
you thank you very much for hosting us
it's it's indeed not only a pleasure
also a privilege and an honor to be here
with you today and it's absolutely true
that we came here to meet with you
discuss with you interact with you to
talk about real strategy for a real car
with real people and we we took the
stance of avoiding the 100 slide lecture
by bringing the people the executives
who input the energy in the system to
make things happen and those people are
here with us today and you'll see they
are quite lively people and I'm enjoying
every day when I have the pleasure again
under privileged to work with them so
I'm just going to start by introducing
them so I will use my documents because
their resume is so rich that I could of
course not memorize that and I will
start by Alfonso Alfonso a bison the
gentleman over here he is the vice
president of nice InDesign America in
San Diego California Alfonso is
responsible for design activities for
the Americas region and plays a part in
planning future design strategies for
the nissan and infiniti brands most
recently Alfonso oversaw the design
development of new vehicles including
the Nissan Juke Ultima maxima and rogue
alfonso began his career as an
automotive designer in 1988 when a joint
neeson as a recent graduate of the Pratt
Institute in New York we have just next
to him Tricia young Jonathan upon
graduating from Harvard Business School
in 2002 Trisha is the director and chief
marketing manager of
vico marketing and sales strategy with
responsibility for developing a
comprehensive strategy for the launch of
the Nissan Leaf Trisha was recently
selected as one of the 100 leading woman
in the North American auto industry by
Automotive News we have then a mark over
there we call him dr. mark you will
understand later why is a Nissan North
America veteran with more than 25 years
and numerous roles throughout the sales
and marketing organization but mostly as
I think you'll learn mark is an EV guy
mark drove the ultra EV in 1992 when he
worked on nissan's first EV
demonstration project in the United
States mark is the director of product
planning responsible for many cars
innocence night lineup but for the past
two years he has lived and breathed the
Nissan Leaf mark is a graduate of
Virginia Tech and like several on this
stage began his life as an engineer we
have then David mingle next to him David
is a graduate of the University of
Illinois where he earned both is
bachelor and master degrees in economics
he has spent eight years at nissen and
also developed experience outside of the
company as president and CEO of Catco
jato dynamics and as president of chrome
systems incorporated today David serves
at Nissan as senior director customer
management and business strategy where
he oversees Nissan North America's
customer contact points including the
websites call centers and lead
management activities last but not least
you have Tracy Woodward Tracy is a
director of government affairs at Neeson
where she has worked as the company's
chief lobbyist in the United States for
ten years Tracy is a growl
of university of tennessee Evie now
takes up well over one hundred percent
of her time so these are the real people
were making it happen and before I start
describing you a little bit more about
our strategy I would like just to show
you a very small video
introducing the one hundred percent
electric Nissan Leaf innovation for the
planet innovation for all I suppose you
got it furnace and the polar bear was a
provocative concept that signaled to
consumers that Neeson is at a
transformative moment in history the
status quo is no more the environment is
hanging in the balance consumers
priorities are shifting and
transportation is adapting with this
changing world as you can imagine some
found this ad to be polarizing Rush
Limbaugh for example called the
commercial pathetic adding that Al Gore
could have written the thing he also
said that the little kids watching this
stuff may think it's ok to hug a polar
bear we hope that's not the case on the
other hand USA Today said the ads
engages the viewer then hammers home the
message save the planet one leaf at the
time other reactions and there were
countless reactions came from multiple
perspectives across the spectrum but
nobody disputes that Neeson made an
impact Neeson believes in making an
impact and views zero emission as a once
in lifetime opportunity from zero
emissions technology and the
electrification of transportation we can
change the automotive industry the way
consumers drive and how vehicles are
brought to market our key goal is zero
emission leadership but before there can
be leadership the marketplace needs to
be established right now we are in the
process of creating that market
what's driving the case for change a
number of key trends are bringing
alternative fuel vehicles to the
forefront around the globe the first
revolves around demographics today the
world's population totals 6.7 billion
humans and by 2050 it will reach over 9
billion with regards to Motor Vehicles
today there are 600 million vehicles
worldwide on our planet and by 2050
statistics show that there may be up to
2.5 billion the World Wildlife Fund as
noted that if China catches up to the US
standards of consumption it will require
two planets to sustain our livelihood
for the long run and if the rest of the
world catches up it will require 11 in
addition concerns over the environment
are reshaping consumer perceptions
priorities and demands consumers are
concerned about global warming for
example the intergovernmental panel on
climate change as concluded that there
will be an increase of five degrees
Fahrenheit by the end of the seventh
century in addition our research has
revealed that consumers are looking for
energy independence therefore nation has
made a corporate commitment to reduce
global co2 emission by ninety percent 90
through 2050 advanced technology
vehicles are a key part of this plan
when nissen identified the need to
achieve this goal we did not want to
take an intermediary step by pursuing a
transitional technology instead we focus
our energy on the ultimate solution does
everyone know what this is
it's a muffler and a tailpipe it exists
in all internal combustion-powered
vehicles all hybrid vehicles all dragon
hybrids and all range extenders there is
no tailpipe in a Nissan Leaf because
there are no tailpipe emissions this is
how we define the ultimate solution what
is even more exciting in that advanced
technology is driving new solutions
creating the ultimate conditions to
bring to mass produce your emission
vehicles to fusion given the magnitude
of these changes it was identified early
by the Neeson team that creating a mass
market for electric vehicles and
delivering on our brand promise needed a
breakthrough approach furthermore it was
clear that our current approach to
launching vehicles would not provide the
elastic approach needed to create the
market for electric vehicles in creating
the EV ecosystem Neeson has pardoned
with governments and utilities in the
new states and around the world
including San Paulo Toronto Yokohama and
my homeland of Portugal and it was
during one of these groundbreaking
partnerships where I first met dr.
Manuel opinion professor pinner in june
of 2008 when he served as the minister
of economy and innovation of the
portuguese government I am indeed
grateful that he has asked neeson to be
here today to demonstrate the progress
we have made towards zero emission
mobility today I have with me a team of
brilliant and passionate individuals who
drove this innovation plan through
multiple areas of the business this
approach ensured that we created a total
solution for our customers encompassing
not only the vehicle but the
infrastructure needed to make zero
emissions driving a reality at nissen
every vehicle is born in the design
studio the nissan leaf is
no exception to speak to you about the
innovation that drove this design
process are welcome alfonso x ser vice
president of nice and design america in
San Diego Alfonso the floor is yours
Thank You mr. tomorrow's thank everyone
this has been an amazing journey I mean
as a to be a designer as a way of life
is really a kind of pinch me kind of
thing but when you're able to work on a
project of this scale this magnitude of
collaboration not only with my teammates
here but with governments and just with
with the dreams of of the public really
of how to get involved in in changing
the planet it's been a real real honor
so I want to take a couple of moments
and go slightly Hollywood on you with
the little film strip so you get a
feeling of just what is the life of a
designer in general and what is the life
of a designer inside Nissan so of course
the story has to start with maybe too
much focus on mom on the baby and this
focus and love really created a child
that for the most part stayed within
themselves the kids are playing the
child is you know drawing a big horse on
the sidewalk and as the kid grows up the
children his friends are playing even
harder and he's really even more alone
but this sounds like a kind of sad story
but this time alone this time looking in
this time dreaming really allowed us
later when we um went to college first
of all it wasn't such a sad story
because we found all these people who
are quite similar to us dreamers who
spent most of their time somewhere
floating in another world to then
altogether start to create and great
story that has a nice ending but
actually the ending became more
interesting because as then when you get
into a big company like Nissan and
especially the type of company where we
see ourselves was bringing passion to
the industry you find that you work with
product planning and engineers who share
your passion but their passion is in a
front area so we're floating in a cloud
they're also as passionately making
wanting to make something real and
something deeper so our work actually
became deeper and at the end of the day
more real and we've had the great honor
to work on some really fabulous fabulous
projects but this is one way this is if
this is life ended here fabulous but
actually around three years ago there
started to be some talk around and Trish
and Mark about this fundamental change I
mean electric vehicles have been around
for a while but the idea would land kind
of flat everyone wants one but there was
no infrastructure the time was just
never right enough but all these words
and Nissan we have our ears out people
are starting to talk this is time this
is time mr. going is saying I want to
make this real and everything started
happening and and when we came and
listened to these stories fundamentally
change the way we design a car because
of course left on our own we complete
dreamland we're in the sandbox in
California we're thinking okay okay
we're going to make this ideal shape
when the wind hits the front that moves
around and as it tapers out effortless
beauty but you know kind of the reality
is we want to make a real car for real
people and I think real people would
feel a little embarrassed being in a
30-foot teardrop and actually making the
corner around here I think that'll be a
little tricky and so we this is where
you know the job really starts to get
interesting the collaborations get
deeper and we started looking at okay
let's be the wind and let's start to
imagine how we can make the wind
separate from the vehicle we want it
compact we want it roomy so you can
drive around you can have a wonderful
life you can enjoy the experience but
the wind must think it's leaving this
form effortlessly so in the rear end as
you can see in the very beginning we
started playing with little elements
that allow the wind to separate because
what happens in aerodynamics as the wind
flows through the car
but as it leaves the car you don't want
it to kind of come around the corner and
basically holds the car which an
electric vehicle burns battery which you
want to save so these early experiments
we actually started thinking all this is
kind of interesting this is a kind of
new way of designing a car and some
things that started happening in
collaborations we found that as we're
working the body side very smooth the
silhouette moving very smooth that some
tricks started to come up like let's say
for the maybe we don't think about
headlamps that much in our normal day
and but the headlamp itself we
discovered that if we create a shape
that bulged up around the headlamp it
would separate the wind and actually
bypass the side mirror well okay what's
the big deal with that except an
electric vehicle doesn't have an engine
it has an electric motor which is dead
silent so when you're on the freeway any
little thing that's sticking out or in a
weird shape creates noise creates drag
so you had to get into these deep
studies and go into the clay going to
wind tunnel computer simulations of how
the wind flows beautifully and
effortlessly through the body of the car
and creates no friction and no noise so
this kind of was a real big learning and
I'm hoping that we could take this
learning later into you know all forms
of our designs to make all of our cars
super efficient and as you can see the
leaf is starting to take shape we want
five passengers this is a real car we
want sleek effortless design and at this
point is when as designers we start
thinking of some key words to finish the
project so this smart fluidity that the
wind again is the key effortlessness is
the key and here we can then start to
finish the car and as designers we start
looking at all the little details and
let's just you know make sure that the
concept is all right with everyone and
that we don't lose any of the benefits
of the the process some key elements
that did stay the rear as you can say
state this little crease because it
worked beautifully
be the headlamp stayed high on hood and
off the surface and it directs the wind
away from the rear common from the side
mirror and also the the lower of the car
is completely cleaned up so that we can
get again the wind flowing through the
car so that's a little story now
interior design supercritical but on
this car it's almost like I have to tell
another story because when you drive the
first prototype around two years ago
you've realized that when you get in the
car you put it in forward gear no sound
and this is fundamentally different you
hit a button to engage the car basically
no sound so we came we came obsessed by
this whole experience this is a car that
doesn't act exactly it doesn't respond
exactly like a car so when we were
thinking okay we're going to really
let's see if we can create the sense of
peaceful harmony in the general
environment and because it is an EV we
wanted these very simple human flow so
the when you're in you're almost like a
cloud peaceful and the car is not making
any noise and but then we really need to
have some high-tech symbolism because
this is an EV it's a high-tech it has
communications you can communicate with
your car and we wanted all these
elements to be shown in the design so at
the end of the day the design was very
simple has some high-tech elements we
concentrated very much and how clear we
can give this information because it's
new information it's not gasps I have
less it's how much range where's the
next where's the next place for me to
get a charge so every simple message
stated quite clearly and one of the most
important elements is as I mentioned
this is completely different experience
so why have a shifter so we worked very
hard on how's the interface between when
you get in the car turn it on put it
into forward movement so the even the
shift area drive by wire is completely a
new experience so I mean today I've been
kind of talking about the
but the design is not the full story
because it's the people the time and
Tricia is the perfect person to explain
that to you for years we've been hearing
people in the public talking about need
for Environmental Conservation for
recycling programs things like that but
the truth is is it's only been the last
few years that we've started to see
people actually putting prioritization
into environmental factors in their
decision-making on purchasing goods so
as we're bringing an electric vehicle to
market it's a wonderful technology but
we have to understand who is our
consumer what is it that they're looking
for in prioritizing and as a result
market research becomes a very important
element for us who is this consumer also
with the new technology you're talking
not just necessarily about one consumer
but maybe multiple and in fact with a
new technology we know often early
adopters are more willing to come in
pursue a new product and then you have
to sell later to a pragmatic majority a
mass-market consumer so who are they and
they differ our early-adopter consumer
for the nissan leaf is one that very
much is open to new ideas is the type of
consumer that sees opportunities and
says why shouldn't I be doing this this
is an opportunity for us to make a
difference to become more green and they
embrace those things in their life in
fact many of them likely already have
adopted a healthy lifestyle may be
purchasing organic foods may have
considered or put solar panels on their
house might have been some of the first
Prius hybrid owners and these people
also they're out there they want to be
seen as leaders they're not going to be
evangelistic but they do want to
definitely take action and be seen and
noted for the actions that they're
taking and they do have a strong social
network they're very close they
communicate with each other very girly
and the expectation is that companies
need to be very transparent honest
genuine or they will identify it and
call us out on those types of things so
as a result their needs for a vehicle
they're looking for something that's
going to be distinguishing help them
really show their environmental
activities something that's also still
going to be smart and sent
for them they still need a car that's
going to work and function but they are
going to be willing to make some changes
in their life to adopt a green
technology that they believe in and what
we see now from these consumers is very
clearly they see electric vehicles as
the right technology for today we do
have some consumer research we're going
to show you to help you hear it from
their own words I stopped eating meat
when I was 14 and one of the big things
was in fact to have on our planet I
would like to go further you know with
my car in my home in ways that I can oh
my kids to see that too you know this is
the way to go there's like six of us now
the dry Priuses it's really funny I've
probably gotten like 15 people who I
prism electric ecology is the right
solution I feel like why not basically
it's fast it's clean why are we not
jumping on but I'm just so much better
this is the way if you try me can hop on
the bandwagon hopefully other people
will do the same human make a difference
so our early-adopter customer is the one
who's going to be out there right now
one of the many reservations we have
purchasing the Nissan Leaf bringing it
into their household and they're going
to be a very key part of the experience
for us because they will set the initial
precedents and expectations for how this
vehicle will integrate in their lives
and what consumers should expect but
they're not going to be our mass-market
customer that's not where we're going to
get the future volumes we need for our
economies of scale to truly make it an
affordable car for them so as a result
we have to look at our pragmatist
consumer this is the mass market
consumer who thinks green wants to be a
part of it but definitely is a lot
slower to adopt they're going to be much
more calculated in their decision-making
looking and evaluating what is out there
and they'll follow without any issue if
it makes sense for them but they have to
be able to integrate the green elements
into their lifestyle today they're not
going to be willing to adapt their lives
to it recycling is fine but they're not
necessarily going to drive over to the
recycling center they're going to wait
until it's on the curbside so they can
just bring it out to the street and they
don't want those inconveniences so when
we look at their car needs first and
foremost it's all about how does this
integrate into their lifestyle it has to
be a practical car absolutely meeting
all their knee
they're not willing to make any
compromises so no inconveniences that
public infrastructure becomes a very
important thing in terms of the charging
and once those needs are met then
they're willing to adopt a green
technology incorporated into their lives
but they do want to see others take that
first chance with it and prove out that
technology they need to know that it is
a proven technology that they can rely
on and they think v's are very likely
going to be the solution for tomorrow
again we have another video to help you
get a feel for what this consumer get a
lot of reviews that we provide before I
buy I don't it'll be violating on
impulse not the first to adopt because
usually that's where all the problems
live as a lot of bugs I wait cuz this
could only be a second car because for
instance for me is in perfect my job but
I want to go to ban him in trouble JP or
we can I have to get this I'm open to
whatever is coming I think it has to do
all the things that my current car does
for me if it suddenly becomes a major
element of planning in my life I'm not
going to do it so while Nissan wants to
be a leader in zero emissions we need to
be very cognizant that a lot of the
consumers out there may not be at the
same level we are so we've done a lot of
work and research to identify this but
we need to help work with the consumers
to help educate them about key terms
like the difference between battery
electric vehicle range-extended electric
vehicle those types of things that we
need to have a conversation with
consumers really having a dialogue where
we're discussing answering and asking
questions so that we can understand if
this makes sense and also leveraging
third parties because while Nissan can
communicate specifically about zero
emissions and how important it is it
becomes far more credible of a
communication if other people are
involved as well saying the same
messaging reinforcing the direction that
we're going so much more of that than
the typical advertising of just put it
on TV and here's your price point come
in and buy it also we need to prove that
technology is real when people drive it
they know that this is a real car so
part of our marketing activities are
going to go out to consumers we have a
tour going on right now consumer test
drives where they have a chance to drive
it and then they can share those
experiences
via social media so others may be who
have not experienced it are still
hearing from people about how real
incredible the vehicle is for them and
we need to leverage our early adopters
in our bleeding edge these people are
not only passionate about the technology
for themselves but as you heard they
want to influence others to also adopt
so if we can provide them with access to
the vehicle give them conduit and
mediums that they can use to communicate
to others they're going to help convince
the pragmatic majority that this is the
right vehicle for them so once we
understand who the consumer is then we
really have to make sure that we've got
the right product for them so the
consumer information is taken product
planning then works very clearly to
identify what are the critical needs for
the consumer what are the nice to have
elements maybe also what things
shouldn't be on there at all and mark
Perry our Director of Product Planning
works as that interface with engineering
via functions within the sales and
marketing group and the consumer to
identify what are the correct vehicle
needs that we need not only for our
early-adopter but for the pragmatic
majority customer as well mark thanks
Trish I'm not really a doctor I'm a
psychiatrist I've got dreamers in the
design studio I got early adopters who
absolutely know for a fact what the heck
you've been waiting for word you don't
have an electric car out should have
been out 20 years ago and then I've got
the pragmatist that Trish just described
who are absolutely I'm not going to be
first this thing has to be real and I
don't believe it until I see it on the
street so you got to be a psychiatrist
and then you got engineers who say this
is what we can do all that other stuff
is fine but this is what we have to do
because we have to actually build this
car get it to market and make sure that
it's six success so that's what it's all
about but really just a little bit of
step back and we just threw a bunch of
information at you as far as
range-extended and hybrids and electric
vehicles basic we have to start with
some consumers about what is this
technology and really what it's all
about we're all very familiar with
gasoline-powered engines right 100 years
worth of infrastructure car's engine
ends your dad worked on it and they're
in the driveway we all know that but now
all of a sudden we have new technology
actually an electric vehicle is pretty
simple it's got a battery it's got an
electric motor and it's got a plug
that's it the fuel source is pure
electricity comes out of the battery
pack that's it now everything else is
some kind of blend if you're not doing
just a gasoline internal combustion
engine motor car then everything else is
some version of a hybrid but there's so
many flavors of hybrids that they've had
to come up with new names for them so
hybrids you know everybody knows what a
Prius is you kind of know what that is
that's a very small battery hooked up to
an internal combustion engine motor pure
you know hybrids like that they can
maybe do two miles on pure electric
power everything else you're emitting
co2 you're burning gas everything else
you kind of move down the continuum then
to a vehicle that maybe has a little bit
bigger battery a little bit more range
until you get something called a range
extended or an advanced plug-in hybrid
they both mean the same thing the only
difference is how far do you go on pure
electricity before that gasoline motor
kicks in and actually helps move you
down the road or in some cases actually
is an on it does book two things that
moves you down the road and actually as
a generator you know think about that
generator you have when there's an ice
storm you're trying to keep your lights
on it acts like a generator actually to
produce the energy to put back in the
batter pack and go so that's what all
that rest of that stuff is pretty
complicated pretty expensive compromises
everywhere because if we're really
trying to get rid of this there's only
one way to do that electricity zero
mission no tailpipe no gas no oil none
of that stuff ever touches the car again
and that's what we set out to do so the
bet the breakthrough was in the battery
itself don't think of batteries like you
think of flashlight batteries or maybe
what's in your lap top of your cell
phone that's technology of about ten
years ago batteries today now look like
license plates they're about that wide
they're about that thin they're about
that size you stack those cells up to
make up a module have a certain amount
of voltage you do a bunch of those
modules together
figure out how much do you want to do to
actually make the car work drive and go
the amount of range you know the
engineering challenge is how many of
those what is it cost you're hoping that
Alfonso's team has made a very slippery
car so it's going through the air very
easily so you don't need as much energy
and then where do you put it you guys
may know many e well what they do well
they gave up the back seat they gave up
the trunk they piled all those batteries
back there and you had you took a four
seater and made it a two seater well
that's not the mass market so we try to
do is again find that shape that Alfonso
gave us and then look at that battery
pack and say where could you put it it's
underneath the car you're actually
sitting on it so r underneath the front
seats second row and in the rear seats
so it's actually packaged think of about
laptops just kind of pack them all up
stand them up and that's what makes up
the car battery pack 600 pounds dead
center in the car no sacrifice to
Headroom legroom knee room put two golf
bags in the back or a whole bunch of
boxes completely functional efficient
design and well packaged the car itself
and just on one sheet of paper what is
it all about it's a five-door hatchback
the EPA calls us midsize and so does
hurts an enterprise but we call it a
compact you can't get five adults in the
car itself we've had six foot five guys
three across in the back seat Tracy and
I had a bet with a member of the House
of Representatives one of his staffers
not one of the representatives one of
the staffers that she couldn't put three
car seats across the back well you can
we won that we want a steak dinner from
her so we're going to collect that next
week but you could you know if that's
the car really to make it functional and
efficient you see 90 mile an hour top
speed up there again consumers
especially those pragmatism this is just
a glorified golf cart uh-uh it
accelerates 90 mile an hour top speed
and actually we've had in the last two
weeks about 250 journalists from you
know Canada to Argentina up and down the
entire Americas come drive the vehicle
and they made me a liar they hit 95 so I
said you know please we don't we don't
condone speeding in the state of
Tennessee
they did go out on the interstate and
hit 95 miles an hour with four people in
the car so it more than capable of doing
that typical engineers they always hold
a little pad and reserve they don't tell
you about it so the car does 95 you see
24 kilowatt hour battery on board you
know people are start learning now about
miles per kilowatt instead of miles per
gallon we don't have gallons we have an
infinite number of range when you think
about gallons of gasoline because we
haven't we don't have any we have miles
per kilowatt now and then there's a lot
of information technology loaded in the
car so you can have a much more personal
relationship than you're with your
vehicle that maybe you've had in the
past why a hundred miles worth of range
this is where the marketing challenge
that Trish's team is facing versus the
reality that's where they collide
ninety-five percent of us drive less
than 100 miles a day that's just fact
perception-wise is we go if we think we
go farther we're sitting in traffic for
two and a half hours we think that's
distance no that's not distance that's
time we only go 100 miles a day the
first naysayers then come up and say ahh
how about the weekends everybody travels
and goes on trips on the weekends we'll
look at the data doesn't matter weekday
weekend doesn't really matter that much
then you start slicing that pie down
because what we're trying to figure out
is where that sweet spot is about how
much range battery size and cost vehicle
sighs what's the right kind of mix of
all those variables because they do tend
to compete almost three-quarters us go
less than 50 miles a day twenty-seven
percent of us go less than 10 miles a
day these are this is just facts you do
this in Japan saying you do this in
Europe saying you do this in China same
we don't go that far every day so now
the the jump is versus the what if what
if I need to go pick my boss up at the
airport you know those kind of on-off
trips versus the fact is I don't go that
far so a vehicle with 100 miles of range
meets my daily needs it can be your
primary car if you define primary as the
one you use every day are you going to
pull a boat behind this car no you go
four-wheeling know it
not his purpose its purpose is your
daily use card but if you want more than
100 we're going to find ways for you to
do it we have in the economy mode in the
vehicle itself that little shifter that
Alfonso was describing it very easily
another another mode in the car itself
we add more braking we're actually
putting energy back in the pack we
changed some things in the vehicle we
find ways to give you ten percent more
range so as a driver you know what
happens with miles per gallon and your
fuel tank in your car all it does is go
down actually you can actually add range
to your vehicle as you're driving around
with this car another thing that we work
very closely with Alfonso's team plus
purchasing is the vehicle itself we
thought of the vehicle holistically from
a sustainability standpoint it would
have been enough to bring out a vehicle
with a hundred miles worth of range that
was affordable and the first mass-market
electric car that we could have said go
it done and that's that's enough for
this trip will wait for the next
generation but then we went into the car
itself and said how else can we make it
sustainable you saw in the first
commercial that we ran the little piece
of everything you see there in green is
made up of recycled water bottles so we
took the materials users you can
actually turn the stuff in the fabric
now something that we've never done
before so we actually had worked we
found out that was actually being used
in carpets i means a lot of carpet made
out of recycled materials now but we
hadn't actually turned it into seat
fabric so again working with Alfonso's
team purchasing the engineering
community for durability how do we find
ways to make a bigger story so actually
99% of the vehicles weight is completely
recoverable and recyclable all those
things you see there in the explosion
diagram are all those parts that are
either made out of recycled materials
coming in or the ability to recycle
coming out another little obstacle that
we came up with Alfonso was describing
how quiet the car is well then all of a
sudden we started hearing about very
concerned interest groups pedestrians
parking garages kids visually impaired
these cars are quiet I don't know
they're there bikers all of us were
their ear buds right in our ears walking
around between trying to cross the
street here they're dead silent notice i
said dead got to be careful so we
actually had
figure out both in the lab and actually
do the infield tests to figure out that
we needed to make artificial sound now
that some of you guys are MBA students I
understand there is not going to be
ringtones for your car that's not the
you know the big idea that somebody's
going to it's going to be regulated but
right now we're ahead of regulations
we're going we actually had to
artificially make sound now we put
people on street corners and put hats on
I'm earmuffs you know in February
driving cars back and forth in front of
them so we could learn when they found
where cars were what was the sound that
was needed to be made they could pick it
up and then how far away it was and then
we also learned as you age frequency
makes a big difference you you probably
hear much better than I do at high
frequency so we had to chain even work
on that so the car makes noise 0 to 18
miles an hour then it turns off we
learned that enough tire and wind noise
going by that you didn't need it after
that point but again another little
challenge that we had bringing the car
to market lots of information in the car
again on the psychiatry side range
anxiety is a phobia only if you don't
have information you're worried about
something you don't have the information
you worry about it you have anxiety we
have a nut with all kinds of technology
in the car to tell you range energy
usage distance to empty everything that
you need to do right down to just you
know push a button on the steering wheel
up pops on your nav screen reachable
area you have to sit there and calculate
do I have enough range to make it push a
button car tells you it's telling you
autumn every and updates as you drive
and constantly changes so you know where
you are so you don't have any anxiety we
believe technology is the pill dr. Phil
is going to have a show but I think it
got canceled because he saw what we did
in this car and kind of gave up we're
got to have apps you're going to have a
personal relationship again just on your
phone you're going to be able to talk to
your car you're going to be able
understand it's plugged in the parking
garage out that you're sitting in class
going ok I need fifty percent state of
charge in order to get home dial up your
car and ask it well where are you well
I'm at forty seven percent I need a
couple extra minutes before I'm ready to
go you're plugged in at home you all of
us plug in plug in these things right
that's
we live we get home we plug these things
in well if you happen to forget your cut
plug in your car and we had that from
consumers well what if I wake up in the
morning I forgot to plug my car and I
can't get to work ok real concern dog
ate my homework I get that car is going
to send you a text or an email and say
hey you forgot to plug me in you can sit
here you know those cold mornings in
February instead of using battery power
to heat up the car you'll actually be
able to dial up your car and say hey
warm it up to 75 degrees before I get in
using grid power versus battery power
you know flip that around its July and
it's 90 s cool it down you'll be able to
do that from from your phone so all
those things are there and again that
kind of relationship now that the car
now is another device that you have that
kind of interconnectivity and able to do
that but then we have the pragmatist all
that stuff's cool for the early adopters
so that's all great you know it's the
stuff you talk about to your friends and
you know look look what my car can do
it's got a solar panel on it and all
those things but now you got the
pragmatists that are going to do the
math so the whole point of the pricing
position that we took with the vehicle
and the the difference between gasoline
and electricity is where we want to make
sure there are no premiums involved in
using this car hybrid suffered because
of price premium you had to pay to 35
thousand dollars more to drive a hybrid
than you had to drive a regular gasoline
car with this same or less no payback
period just look at the math you spend
on an annual basis you spend driving
around you know 25 miles a gallon car
three dollar gallon gas you spend about
twelve cents a mile just to drive around
just the math drive electric you're
under three you look at those numbers on
the screen eighteen hundred dollars a
year to drive gasoline lest they have
396 to drive electric so those guys that
the pragmatists are doing the math one
whom i'm saving money doing this oh yeah
it's green yes zero emission yeah yeah
yeah but I'm saving money that's what
they're interested in number one reason
why they're interested in the car save
money number two number three is some
version of green sustainable zero
emission
one reasons i'm going to save money they
are the pragmatists so we got a pretty
unique car pretty innovative you know we
set it out you know to make it make a
statement with a vehicle but we had an
existing sales process that needed to be
changed and we needed to get a sales
process to change as innovative as the
car is and Dave mingle is going to stand
up is ahead of our customer management
office to actually show you what we did
to actually change the entire experience
on the consumer side to get one of these
thank you Mark now you understand why we
call them the doctor which would pass
out order forms right now well at a
minimum I think you should know by now
how special this car is going to be and
we knew from the start that a special
car was going to need a very special
sales process so what we did first like
all good marketing people do is we went
out and talked to our customers how
should we bring this car to market
here's what they told us educate me
about everything especially those early
adopters they want to know everything
about the car absolutely no surprises
full transparency about all of the
capabilities of this car they want us to
make it easy for them put it all in one
place easy-to-read formats and keep them
informed as new information becomes
available this is an evolving
marketplace it's an evolving technology
things change all the time they want us
to make sure that we're the ones taking
the responsibility to push information
out to them so they can stay informed
and importantly respect them respect my
time and interest in your company why do
we need to listen real simple the EV
value proposition as should be pretty
obvious by now is totally different than
that from a gasoline car or even a
hybrid car things like charging
infrastructure driving range mobile
connectivity how are you going to use
that cell phone to communicate with your
car and tax incentives which Tracy will
talk to you about next are all unique
aspects that a customer has to know
about to make an informed decision to
buy this car if we don't take the
responsibility to inform them at a
minimum they can be confused in worst
case they become dissatisfied owners
which i'm pretty sure Carlos is not in
my job description let me give you an
example who knows what an EV se is mark
I thought we'd have at least one hand
come on but don't worry I didn't know
what it was about a year ago either it's
the electric vehicle service equipment
or what we call a charging dock this is
what you're going to have in your garage
or available to you out into the public
to charge the car it's 240 volts same as
your clothes dryer but will require
permitting and professional installation
second question for you how many have
tried to pull an electric permit ever
well it's not gonna be a very pleasant
experience for you if you try to do it
by yourself that's why we have taken it
upon ourselves to line up a whole
network of installers to be able to do
that for our customers so this process
can be very seamless and easy for them
so how do we pull this off we created
what we call the leaf customer journey
the lCJ it's a place where our customers
can come and learn everything they need
to know to decide if the nissan leaf is
right for them they'll be able to shop
including configuring a car that we will
in fact build for them to their exact
specification including their desired
color it's a place where they'll be able
to reserve and actually place a vehicle
order online with the dealer of their
choice ultimately when the car becomes
available for them to pick up they'll be
able to arrange delivery with one of our
local dealers to take delivery of the
car and take at home after they have at
home on lCJ we're going to have a full
range of ownership tools off of our own
or portal including additional mobility
apps as the ones mark already showed you
and a big breakthrough for the industry
we're going to do this with no dealer
stock
our plan is to sell one hundred percent
of our production before we ever ship
the vehicle to one of our dealers so you
can visit one of our dealers and you'll
see lots of great cars like our Nissan
Maxima or flagship car for the nissan
brand but you will not see a Nissan Leaf
so how are we doing so far we've had
over 5 million unique visitors to the
Nissan Leaf microsite since we opened it
up about a year ago over 250,000 think
the number as of this morning Carlos is
252 have now signed up as what we call
hand razors they have provided us at a
minimum an email address so we can stay
in in constant contact with them and
push to them some of that information I
talked about earlier and that mark
described we have about 20,000 folks
that have played a $99 reservation fee
to be among the first in their
marketplace to order the vehicle when it
goes on sale and we have about 3,000
folks that have already placed
appointments for one of our EVSE
installers are charging dock installers
to come by their house and give them a
quotation for what it's going to take to
have that equipment in the garage all of
these numbers far exceed what we
expected at this point in fact back in
September we actually shut down the
reservation system because we were that
far ahead of our initial goals so with
that I'd like to turn it over with to
Tracy who's going to talk to you about
how we're going to bring public charging
infrastructure to life to life we hope
so so we've designed the car we know who
we were going to sell it to we know
what's going to be in it we know how we
want to sell it to them so how are we
going to reach outside the company to do
that when your goal is established
zero-emission leadership what do you
need to do you create a cross-functional
team within the company you get the
government affairs lobbyists to help you
reach out to these localities to these
utilities to those states to help you
try to create public infrastructure so
we created a cross-functional team with
a lot of people that I had never worked
with before in the company so this was a
very unique experience for me to
actually work on a vehicle instead of
just policy
so where are we going to start where are
we going to go where are we going to
start selling these cars where are we
going to start creating public
infrastructure so we had to look at a
list of how to layer our road map to
where we're going to go so he looked at
hybrid registrations where are those
current early adopters now we look for
places where there are already
incentives in place Oregon already had
an incentive in place where where things
left over from the first go-round with
electric vehicles you research green
rankings city rankings places that have
sustainability plans already in place
and then we used 20 years worth the
networking in connections to try to open
doors for us who do we go talk to so
with all of that we were able to see
where we needed to go first and
obviously the west coast was on the top
of our list with that we also decided
that we were going to take a different
approach to this we were going to try to
do this very holistically and we were
going to try to do it very personally so
there has been a lot of one-on-one
attention to this between mark and I and
a few others we've collected over 1400
business cards which represent 27 states
and 308 cities we've done countless
presentations and webinars so what
you've heard today is two and a half
years worth of him getting his story
straight with in addition to the
consumer tour we are doing now we've
also done to prototype tours our last
one hit 27 cities and 67 stops so we
have really reached out and touched a
lot of people personally and we think
it's made a big difference so what are
we talking to these people about we're
wanting them to get plug-in ready or EV
ready and but what we mean by that is
incentives for customers not for Nissan
not for other OEMs but for the customers
financial incentives tax rebates tax
credits or things like free parking HOV
Lane access anything that will create an
incentive for a customer to want to buy
our car what Dave talked about we want
to streamline that permitting an
inspection
process so it's as short as possible
we'd like to get it down to three to
five business days worst-case scenario
is you get your car have to wait six to
eight weeks to get your home charging
dock we don't want that to happen so our
target is three to five business days
things we run into municipalities and
states have local rule so everybody's in
charge of their own system so we've
tried to create a best practice self
inspection online permitting different
ways that you can go about streamlining
this process charging infrastructure
they know locals know their areas better
than we do where are those iconic
locations where you can put charging
where as a public municipality can you
put charging in your own lots where can
you put it on street maps so people will
know it's there don't eat a lot to start
out with but you do need a level of some
to make sure that people know it's there
and they can charge if they need to
education and public outreach things
like we're doing today educating people
is coming it's real we have to get ready
it takes a year you know everybody
working together so that's what we've
been trying to do the utilities we've
been trying to work with the utilities
we're sharing a customer now we have to
reach out to them we don't want to be a
pain point for them we have to be able
to work together with the utilities to
make sure that they were promoting home
charging at night we don't plug in at
four o'clock in the afternoon when it's
very hot outside and cause problems for
the grid so when you're plugging ready
this is what it's going to look like
you're going to have your utility you're
going to have your retail lot like a
Best Buy or home depot or something with
charging in it you're going to have
charging stations along the street in
parking lots and in your house so we
envision that this is what a EV
ecosystem would look like and this is
what we need to work toward these are
just some more examples Dave showed you
our home charging dock that's in the
middle but there's some other examples
DC fast charge other street parking the
upper right is actually the highway sign
for the states of Oregon states of
Washington and California for you to be
able to know where you can EV charge or
in the
CDs and then along the highways there
are currently a hundred and six thousand
gas stations with convenience stores in
the US as of july of this year by the
end of next year there's going to be
13,000 level two public charging
stations that does not count the number
of home charging stations that people
will be putting in and it does not count
the number where they'll be our dealers
will have them available as well so you
can see these are going to proliferate
really quickly department of energy one
of the things we've been working on with
them is this sort of thing with the
public charging this is a result of our
two and a half years worth of work july
of 2008 we announced our MoU with the
state of tennessee didn't really count
home home field advantage right how
corporate headquarters is their
manufacturing is there not a big deal
november 10th 2008 we announced our
partnership agreement with the state of
oregon that was a big deal Green State
eco-friendly really opened a lot of eyes
we didn't have to knock on doors is hard
then people started knocking on our
doors this is the result of that we've
had people reach out to us this morning
we met with Seward Park free-market
cooperative largest free market
cooperative in the city of New York
wanted to talk to us about Evie's want
to talk to us about how they can help
where do they need to put charging
stations how do they need to get people
together to do that spend an hour with
them this morning and in doing all this
Nissan is becoming a policy leader not
only on the federal level but on the
state level as well people are calling
us wanting to know what they can do to
help wanting to make sure they're not a
barrier wanting to see what they can do
to help promote advanced technology
vehicles so this has been a game-changer
for Nissan in that regard to we've
always been a little bit of a maverick
but the EV has really brought us to the
forefront of being human rukh so we are
involved in many places that we can
there's only a few of us that our
government affairs we've deputize all
these people up here to do so as well
but this is where
we come full circle when we start
delivering vehicles in December we will
have come full circle with our two and a
half years of work and now to close us
out on our circle turn it back over to
mr. Tavares thank you thank you tracy
Thank You team let's wrap up let's wrap
up everything which was mentioned and
perhaps that with the fact that the team
has now taking you through how Neeson
has transformed the vehicle lunch
process to meet the demands of the
consumers the opportunity of new
technology and changing needs of the
society we believe this approach not
only will be benchmarked within the
industry but also will become an
industry standard we have made great
efforts to get to this point and yet we
are convinced that this moment is only
the beginning in December you'll see the
first of several all-electric vehicles
on the roads and in the driveways of
people on three continents by 2014 two
more electric vehicles will join
Nissan's product portfolio and electric
commercial vehicle which will bring
emissions-free driving to the world van
sector and a compact infinity electric
vehicle the first EV in the luxury
segment Alfonso talk to you about the
innovative design philosophy of the
Nissan Leaf but imagine a world where
vehicles can be any shape thanks to the
unique packaging abilities of an
electric vehicle Tricia shed light on
our customer profile the more customers
experience zero emissions the closer we
will get to a vehicle ownership
experience that's both guilt-free and
anxiety free the future of product
features is wide open mark shed light on
features such as the vehicle quietness
but imagine a world where the quiet were
of the road is all that's heard
on the highway policymakers and
utilities today are working in tandem
with the automotive industry in places
around the country that Tracy
highlighted but imagine those
communities joining together so it's
possible to shape zero mission roadways
connecting population centers throughout
the United States and it's doubtful that
consumers will want to return to the
whole way of buying a vehicle after
experiencing the white-gloved service
and online convenience that comes with a
journey of buying a Nissan Leaf that
David outline for you are we being too
idealistic too optimistic perhaps but
should we continue to work towards the
creation of a zero-emission society we
think absolutely in closing keeping with
our brand promise Nissan will continue
to push the limits of the automotive
industry long into the future with the
concept of innovation as our core belief
we hope many of you joining us for this
exciting journey and together let's try
to make these things a thing of the past
so would you like the opportunity to
drive a Nissan Leaf thank you right now
we will host a mobile Q&A contest for
three students to win the exclusive
opportunity to drive the nissan leaf
here in new york city in a moment we
will post three multiple choices
questions you must text the response to
three students will be selected from
those who answer all the questions
correctly get out your phones and good
luck you can text your responses to the
questions on the screen 269 302 and now
we look forward to answering your
insightful and I'm sure challenging
questions thank you for your attention
okay so the first one here we go
hi good morning everyone dr. sushma from
Columbia University thanks for the
presentation the strategy aspect was
quite interesting on both sides for the
marketing and the planning part I had
three quick questions the first one is
how much in terms of our dnd budget does
that project represent for any sun or an
order of magnitude to get a sense of how
you do valet of developing that compared
to the other cars because you mentioned
that you don't have them in source the
second one is what exactly does the mou
contain with the states because you
mentioned different aspects but it'd be
interesting to see from the different
states how they perceive and why the
including the mr use and the third part
is a lot of the things that we saw were
about the US but EU is tend to be more
environmentally friendly so why this
focus in the US or are you developing
that they can be us about thanks thank
you well try to answer your three
questions I will take the first one I'll
ask Tracy to take the second one and
probably i'll come back to the to the
third one are indeed you know that
nissan as another strength that we
didn't talk so much about it today is is
the alliance with bruno and this is this
is a very important thing because it
gives us a foundation much broader
foundation to share the R&D costs and of
course the investments of this
significant strategic decision so we
have been doing this since day one both
in terms of R&D in terms of
manufacturing investment to make it
simple we have invested already more
than four billion euros in zero emission
vehicles this embraces R&D and
manufacturing i will perhaps give you a
few more numbers so that you have some
references at this stage the Alliance
has already invested for half a million
battery capacity per year we have
already invested for more than 250,000
electric vehicles
per year and I can tell you we are the
only ones we are the only ones that took
this magnitude of commitment to the zero
emission strategy so it's it's it's
money it's big money but at the same
time it's not disproportionate you can
calculate but what represents the total
the total amount of investment that we
do on on your yearly basis company like
ours is four point five percent of
turnover and you'll see that this this
magnitude represents perhaps a little
bit more than the total investment we do
in in one single year so it's reasonable
and the fact that we have this
partnership with Renault makes makes it
even more powerful moving forward both
on the R&D side and on the manufacturing
side on the R&D side one thing I would
like also to highlight is that this is
not the story of a car as you heard it's
the story of bringing a full portfolio
of vehicles and you know that both renew
and nice and now having the pipe eight
electric vehicles and that's going to be
of course a competitive edge for both
companies so trace you would like to
answer the segment sure be glad to
answer when we started this out we were
operating blindly as well so when we
started approaching these places to have
the initial memorandum memorandums of
understanding what we wanted to them was
a formalized agreement it was
non-binding what it was doing was
bringing the interested parties together
to roll up our sleeves to sit down and
work together to figure out what we all
needed to do we needed to roadmap the
permitting inspection process how many
days does it take how little short can
we get it and look at public charging
what laws need to be changed are there
opportunities for incentives some states
were a little bit more aggressive than
others some already had things in place
and we didn't have to do that but by and
large when we started these partnership
agreements it was more of a
formalization of our working together it
also was a marketing opportunity because
the announcement of these partnership
created press it created buzz it started
creating the perception that this was
really a movement which it was so
different ones had different things are
all about the same you know you start
looking at those things that we wanted
them to do to be market-ready and it was
laying out the roadmap for how we were
going to get there Thank You Tracy I'll
take that the third question animal make
the transition you know we we thought
perhaps we were wrong that we should
focus more on the United States today
but this is a worldwide strategy that's
very clear and to use the MOU question
one of the commitments that we were
looking for when we work with
governments and I'll take here the
example of of Portugal where this was
discussed and agreed with the professor
Pino at that point in time was the
commitment from the government that they
would install a certain level of density
of charging units because we were
mindful of the customer experience and
we didn't want to bring the car if there
was no infrastructure so one of the
major pillars of those mo use was the
commitment from the official entity that
a certain number of charging units would
be there and of course from aside the
commitment that we would bring the car
in a timely manner in Portugal for
instance there were multiple local
agreements between the government and
the 25 major cities of the country so
that they would install those charging
units with a certain number of
milestones I remember there was one by
the end of 2010 and another one by the
end of 2011 so that's one of the one of
the examples in Europe we have multiple
partnerships we have partnerships with
the UK we have partnerships with Denmark
with Ireland of course we are also
working with a lot of prefectures in in
Japan in Yokohama and across the country
we have discussions ongoing in China we
also signed mo use in Australia in the
Americas we have mo use agreements with
Toronto with Quebec with van
hoover we have an agreement with mexico
city there will be in november a very
important world mayor summit where all
the mayors of big cities come to Mexico
City to discuss what they can do to
accelerate the proliferation of electric
vehicles we have an MoU with the city of
San Paulo so you know it's we have an
MoU with chili it's it's a worldwide
strategy and we for the sake of
simplicity we just thought that we
should focus on the u.s. terday thank
you so much thank you so much for the
presentation just two brief questions
the first one is do you that guys have
any data on the net emissions saved I
mean you did some data with the cost but
I'd be interested to see if you know
taking like the world energy mix or even
the US energy makes the power mix of how
much emissions would it would it take to
charge your car as compared to the
emissions given up from burning oil and
the second question is is I found it
interesting about the ninety-five
percent of consumers but I'm definitely
part of that pragmatist group and that
lasts five percent I'm sorry the
ninety-five percent of consumers you
drive in less than hundred miles that
last five percent i think is huge you
know i just took a weekend trip to
boston if i owned a leaf i wouldn't be
able to get there in a car so what are
you guys doing in the future you know
future innovations like weather
expanding the battery expanding the
mileage range i made possible event
joint ventures with you know anything
with providing oil burning cars for a
weekend you know you know using like a
hertz or something or using other nissan
cars that that leaf consumers can
utilize thank you thank you for your
your question especially the second one
even the first one because we love being
challenged and you absolutely correct in
a highlighting those two points so I'll
take the first one and probably ask dr.
mark to answer the second one so first
one is is important topic and this is a
topic that a professor pina knows very
well so you can also jump in if he if he
thinks it's necessary you know we use
to talk about the well to will energy
consumption and for the sake of the
explanation i would like to break it
down in well to tank and tank to will so
we as a car maker considered these our
responsibility to address the tank to
will which is the mobility device so
from a tank two-wheel perspective from a
mobility device perspective we have now
a solution not a smaller pot a smaller
car a real solution because it's zero no
tailpipe no gas then you have the wheel
to tank which is how you provide the
energy and what's the footprint of that
of that energy in terms of of carbon as
we know a lot of countries have
different footprints as you know there
is a worldwide dynamic to go in the
direction of renewable energies and as
you know the starting point of those
countries is different but what is very
important is that everybody is somewhere
moving in the same direction and you
know that if I take two examples in in
in the americas i would say that both
Brazil and Canada have more than ninety
percent of renewal energy rate portugal
is now moving from 40 to 70 I believe
Denmark is in the high 70s also so all
of these countries and all of these
societies understand that renewable
energy is the direction and they will
work in their own footprint of energy
sourcing to improve that that
performance so when you combine well to
tank and tank to wheel you are moving to
a low-carbon overall society and that's
I think what we are doing and then you
can spend a lot of time making
calculations on why in this country an
electric vehicle will gain more tons of
co2 than in another country and you can
also understand why in the United States
we selected some specific markets to
launch the nissan leaf because in those
markets the footprint of energy products
is much more green or renewable than in
other states so that's the answer to the
first part of your question and I will
let mark talk about the anxiety of not
being able to go on weekend I mean the
you raised a very good question and
again that you layer in now the fact is
ninety-five percent of us go less than
100 miles a day a day so that what's
your primary car you layer and then that
there are 12 million cars and trucks new
cars and trucks sold every year we're
not trying to sell all 12 million cars
and trucks to be Evie's another
information about the United States
multiple car households we we have
multiple cars for multiple uses in
general people who buy new cars they
typically have two to three cars in the
household designed for specific
instances this car is designed to be
your daily car not the car to go to
Boston yet yet you have something else
now what is it something else in the
interim that something else an interim
could be car sharing hurts is going is
announcing a car sharing program similar
in concept to zipcar but a little
different now through a rental car
agency and that they're going to be live
here in New York so as another
alternative so again as you look across
the consumer base the first thing is
that people have multiple cars already
so that's what they use to go to Boston
if you don't then you avail yourself of
something else and that something else
could be car share it could be a used
car could be something else now a long
long long term is there a battery
breakthrough in the future gosh I hope
so there's about two and a half billion
dollars just in the United States and
research and development going and not
just not nice on funding but just
funding from lots of various sources so
a lot of people are working on it it's
not there yet a 200-mile batteries just
not there yet but there's a lot of funny
to continue to do research and my
crystal ball is not that good you know
eight to ten years from now there'll be
something just not yet okay thank you
Mark oh ok thanks for giving us a very
comprehensive presentation my name is
Xiao Jing for Syrian my there are two
things that I would like to know more
about first is about
the infrastructure problem things Nissan
is not the only one that's building you
know electrical vehicles right now there
are the companies working on it so as a
consumer out want like standardized
infrastructure Linda charging stations
right for example you know the
standardized plug-in connector or the
power supply or like standardized
battery so my question is does Nissan
Plant to you know partner with other
automobile companies to have this
standardized standardized plug a
standardized infrastructure or does it
plan to you know build the standard on
at all so and my second question is I
think actually do you guys have any
specific plans you open up the market in
China because I think it's actually a
better one because the demand is really
high and it's really easier to you know
build the infrastructure with the
centralized government and the third and
the third is that you know in big sin
big city most people most vehicles are
in big cities in China so people don't
really drive as far as Americans do so
it actually lowers the requirement for
battery race so I well I would like to
know what do you guys plan to do in
China thank you great questions thank
you for moving us east or west depending
on which is your perspective you take
but i will take the opportunity through
your thoughtful questions to introduce
Eric nausea is our vice president of
corporate planning and end programs is
also a very important actor in all the
discussions we are we have been having
so I will ask eric and and Tracy perhaps
to answer your first question about how
are we position ourselves against
standardization Thank You Carol good
morning everyone these are very good
questions and of course we are not
trying to do it on our own we are
working on standardization what David
was showing you in terms of EVs see
already the connectors are standardized
it's the 240 volts plug that you bring
in your current is a standard already in
the US
we didn't really touch base on the the
quick charge which is 480 volt is a
bigger quicker charging stations the
standard doesn't exist yet but we are
working with the SAE to to try to
standardize that you have a few
automakers such as mitsubishi Ford GM
all working together to suddenly and
develop a standard in the US Europe
would be a different story and China
would be will be a different story as
well of course in terms I don't know
what Tracy you want you want to add
anything on that part in there are there
are national associations like a EDTA
electric drive transport association
that all of the OEMs are members of that
are starting to work on that I think in
the beginning those people who
infrastructure is most important to were
out there working you know the things
that we've been doing are not exclusive
we don't want what happened in the late
90s when there were two different
standards to be out there so Eric's
right there's one standard for the
coupler the Society of Automotive
Engineers has gotten all the OEMs to
agree that they will have that same
coupler so any public infrastructure
that's out there will be universal so
that's going to be a big hurdle that
we've gotten over and I will answer your
question about China first to tell you
that you already have a certain number
of Mo you sign with the we Chinese
cities so we are there as you know we we
have a very important presence with a
now more than six percent market share
in China and a very good partner with
the dong Fang and we have significant
activity over there and for the sake of
letting those discussions proceed
properly I will not tell you more today
but we are we are working hard in China
and you are absolutely correct that
there is in China the same i would say
profile as the one that mark highlighted
which is ninety-five percent of the
people don't drive more than 100 miles
and one thing which is interesting is
that China because has a shorter I would
say automotive history as the concern of
short cutting a certain number of
intermediary steps and go down
likely to i would say cleaner mobility
devices so i'm very hopeful that we are
going to progress very quickly over
there also and that's all I can tell you
today but certainly it is in our radar
screen we have cyclic significant
activity over there and we believe that
we can bring something to some of the
big Chinese cities as much as we intend
to bring something to some of the cities
that perhaps faced the same issues like
Mexico City or sample Thank You mr. 5s
and team thank you for sharing your time
with us this morning my name is David
I'm a master's in public administration
finishing up in the spring and my
question is about how the electric car
can interface with renewable technology
moving forward so one of the biggest
hurdles to wind power and solar power is
the intermittency a cloud comes over the
wind stops blowing and you need to have
a gas turbine to pick up that slack and
some thinkers have posited that electric
vehicle network could not only receive
electricity from the grid but then also
feed it back in and be a power source
across the country so that capacity
exists now we're moving forward is that
something I'm looking forward to great
question let me introduce and then and
then perhaps ask mark and Eric to
complement we we are very mindful of the
fact that we need to close the loop on
the battery life cycle we imagine that
there is an automotive likes I've likes
life cycle and then an automotive life
cycle just after and of course there's
non-automotive like Sappho like staff
has a huge potential to positively
interfere with the lifestyle of our
consumers and mostly to the energy
supply of their home so we created a
partnership with a company japanese
company called sumitomo to address the
foot what we call the four hours and of
course I'm going to forget one so I'm
not going to mention this for hours but
they will but the purpose is exactly to
see how we translate this technology on
something else than just the mobility
device as an error
gee supply to the livelihood or to the
lifestyle of the consumers within their
their home so every corner mark wants us
on oh maybe I can start and I'm going to
try to be brief because it's a very wide
subject of course and thanks for the
question the first application for
instance when you think about wind
energy at night you get a wind you don't
know what to do you can't store it now
we've got the car in home that you won't
recharge so you can basically defer some
wind energy directly to the tube to the
cars the sign for instance would be more
appropriate during the day and it's very
clear that we are also working with some
solar panels or saloons in installer to
offer potential you sustainable cycles
so you can abide the Nissan Leaf at the
dealership but some people will also
love to equip their homes with solar
panels and so on so what this is a
natural partnership in terms of
sustainable size sustainability cycle
the other the other part of the equation
is too far you aren't talking and
talking about Carlos forest stands for
recycles resale refurbish and
remarketing the batteries so it's the
second life of the batteries we're also
talking to utilities for instance some
of them you never saw the the problem of
energy storage so now you have batteries
which after five years still have a lot
of capacity or durability they can be
used for storage capabilities so you can
you know that would use substitution to
new power power power plants for
instance you got those batteries and
then you can charge during the day or
during the night you charge the
batteries and then it allows you not to
have a peak during the day I guess the
peak is around twenty percent so we have
twenty percent over capacity in the US
for instance in terms of a power supply
therefore you can you can also create a
sweep the peak and though it's a lot of
energy saving so it's also part of all
the sustainability a problem and
solutions that were bringing here with
the done on your car in a up front but
also the storage
downstream Thank You egg by the way Eric
comes from this university just in case
so you can have a positive judgment of
his answers thank you hi thanks
everybody my name is Luke I'm a mpa
student environmental science of policy
here I used to sell zap cars and other
neighborhood electric vehicles and I
would encounter these as you describe
the pragmatic consumers every day and
the two questions I could count on
getting every single day where range
issues and then battery life issues so
my questions they've kind of were even
covered a little bit but one what does
nissan planning to do about you speak a
lot about the charging infrastructure
but what are you guys planning to do for
technological breakthroughs to really
improve quick charging because you know
charging off 110 that trickle charging
takes hours and my understanding even
the 240 volt charging still takes hours
but there are fast charging technologies
that could charge cars you know maybe 40
minutes or half hour if we can speed
that up then we can pull into a gas
station and charge our cars in 10
minutes and then the range issue is
basically salt so what what are you guys
doing to address those technical hurdles
and then the other issue is course the
battery life which was just talked about
a little bit but you know every day they
would say to me what do i do when my
batteries are dead the cars known were
used to me what is nice on doing to
address those issues for the four for
the real practical purpose of keeping
these cars running for years and years
let me start with the easy part of the
answer and the difficult part will be
for mark so the easy part of the answer
is that we are selling the car with the
battery as one of the components of the
car or leasing the car with the battery
and when we sell the car we are going to
sell the car with a battery warranty of
eight years and 100,000 miles which is
quite I think wide wide warranty so that
we take that anxiety out of the mind of
the consumer by saying look you have a
wide warrant it even goes beyond the
warranty of the car itself so it's it's
our
our responsibility you don't have to
worry about it we can give you a little
bit more details later if you want but I
would like to give mark the opportunity
to answer the other question about the
fast charging and that's exactly what we
believe will help faster adoption is
fast charging and we're launching with
that so you'll see in six states as we
launch in this in December and into next
year the ability that the car will come
with a charge port that actually accepts
480 volt power 0 to eighty percent stay
to charge 30 minutes so plug in it's a
fire hose you get your not going you
probably won't show up at zero so you're
probably talking about your 10 minutes
you'll pick up 40 50 miles you're down
the road and go or actually you know the
work that Tracy's tracing and I we've
been working on at the state level
you'll see those pathway chargers so
we're going to connect places like la
San Diego San Francisco Sacramento
Seattle Vancouver Portland Nashville
Chattanooga Knoxville and what would be
put city of Houston is going to be
completely covered up with DC fast
charging so you'll see it we're not
nationwide yet but we're actually going
to do it thank you shall we answer the
questions for the two gentlemen or you
want to stop so I'll try to go fast
please thank you for coming today and
delivering this great presentation my
name is Martin bajwa roof I'm sip Harlem
and currently working for cornet long
term forecasting group I have two quick
questions so the first one is after how
bright is the future of electric
vehicles after the election results this
Tuesday and my second question is when
you're going to see electric version of
Formula One races thank you Wow I think
I'm going to take this to you now
great questions well for the first one I
would say it's as bright now as it was a
few days ago because this is driven by
by the consumer the consumer is at the
same time the guy who decides to buy or
not to buy and the guy who also
somewhere puts the pressure on the any
government any official to address what
the consumer things are the society
problem so I don't see any any
fundamental fundamental different this
is a very big big shift it's a very deep
trend so I'm very comfortable with with
this kind of change I think it's exactly
as it was a few days before on the
second question which is also a great
point I think there is a lot to do to
demonstrate that electric vehicles are
fun because in the mind of a certain
number of consumers first electric
vehicles are not a real car which we are
now demonstrating is wrong with the
nissan leaf and secondly they are not
fun they cannot be agile which is also
wrong and there are two two kinds of
people I can meet the ones who did the
test drive and the ones who didn't and
there was the ones who did they
understand exactly what I'm saying so
Motorsports may happen from the one I
don't know I think at the beginning it's
going to be a little bit shorter races
given a given the capacity of the
batteries but I can tell you that we
have been doing significant work on what
could be an interesting leverage from a
Motorsports perspective of zero-emission
vehicles and it pencils very well so I
would like to ask you a few month of
patients so that we can come back strong
on that matter but we will do something
about it but certainly not from the one
thank you and the last question I thank
you so much my name is Shimek pose um my
question is really regarding your growth
trajectory for Nissan I wanted to know
you know with the rapid growth led by
developing countries the
consumers are tomorrow of today are
necessarily not going to be the
customers of tomorrow so I wanted to
know how you're going to position Nissan
as a brand in the future are you going
to you in your presentations showed some
signals of reducing margins and you know
increasing volume so it's not a strategy
that you're looking to implement in the
future as more and more people will be
able to afford to buy a car but will it
be an electric car perfect question for
my closing thank you extremely timely
you know you are absolutely right yeah
there are two things we are trying to do
the first one it's correct to say that
Nissan as a growth strategy let me give
you some some figures we just presented
this week our first half financial
results and we expressed the fact that
we are going to grow significantly in
this fiscal year probably close to 4.1
million cars last year we we sold 3.5
and so far the record year of Nissan was
2007 with three-point 77 so you see that
we are stepping out of the crisis very
strong probably to beat our sales record
this year a company we know that and a
company that performed a seven point
eight percent operating profit margin on
the first half which is the similar
level as it was before the crisis so we
are back and we are back very strong now
second part of the answer is about the
nissan brand and we have been saying
that there is something we need to
enhance is the explanation of what
Nissan stands for as a brand and this
has been one of the reasons why our
presence in the United States but not
only is not as large as it should be
because we didn't communicate clear
enough what we stand for as a brand so
what is it we have made significant
research and we came up with a very
hi hope clear statement which is
innovation for all our marketing
campaign and our brand statement is this
one innovation for all and why because
when you look at the products we have
created in the last 10 years if you look
at them one by one each of them
represent in some specific form and
innovation and I could give you several
examples i can let me give you just
three examples the murano crossover
concept was one of the first to be
introduced the nissan gt-r a
high-performance very affordable car the
Nissan Juke with a new very innovative
powertrain also so those are three
examples i could use other ones so we
end up by saying well it's very natural
it's very core it's rooted nissan is
about innovation and it's also somewhere
about affordability so it's innovation
for all now within this brand statement
this is what we want to stand for we
want to own the territory of innovation
and we have a flag and that flag is the
Nissan Leaf because the innovation power
of nissan leaf is obvious i believe for
everybody so using the nissan leaf as
the flag for innovation we want to
communicate that our tree tree is
innovation and its innovation for all
because it's affordable that's my answer
thank
you